o
[Música]
[Aplausos]
quanto será que vale um carro no formato
de peças
o outro dia ouvi uma história de que uma
empresa havia feito um teste que havia
comprado um carro desmontado e tentado
revendê-lo no formato de peças ao invés
de inteiro
e pasmem a história diz que daria para
ter comprado mais de três carros desta
forma
essa não é uma história em comum a gente
ouvir isso muito nos bares e nas rodas
de amigos e esse teste foi conduzido de
maneira técnica pela Porto Seguro
empresa onde eu trabalho
mas porque resolvemos fazer esse teste
hora porque até então a única forma de
se vender um carro era através de
leilões ou na compactação mas no Brasil
apenas um por cento dos veículos são
reciclados enquanto no Japão 99 porcento
dos veículos são reciclados
tá bom foi assim que surgiu a renova
ecopeças a pioneira na desmontagem e
reciclagem de veículos no Estado de São
Paulo
a renova ela consegue destinar as partes
veículos para o reuso e assim os pessoas
podem economizar até setenta por cento
do valor do que seria comprar peças no
balcão
É mas o que mais isso traz para nossa
sociedade
as peças de reuso abrem espaço para o
seguro Popular segura o popular uma
forma mais acessível de seguro aonde
pessoas que até então não poderiam ter
essa segurança e agora podem ter o
seguro é uma forma de proteger o
patrimônio E permitir a ascensão social
para as pessoas a mobilidade EA
sustentabilidade passam por essas
variáveis econômicas nós temos que
encontrar um caminho comum aonde as
coisas façam sentido
eu vou contar mais uma história para
vocês
e nós estamos sempre preocupados em
chegar rápido para atender os clientes
que estão com problemas nas ruas mas no
trânsito de São Paulo caótico como fazer
isso
observando de repente a mobilidade
transformando para bicicletas porque não
agora colocar veículos de serviço em
bikes bikes elétricas
chegando mais rápido para atender nossos
clientes e ao mesmo tempo protegendo
nosso planeta e
hoje a Porto Seguro já conta com uma
Frota de veículos elétricos São carros
picapes bicicletas guincho elétrico que
foi lançado no mês passado primeiro e
Pioneiro no Brasil
e quando pensamos nas mudanças de
hábitos vamos além do serviço do carro e
da mobilidade as pessoas estão com
mudanças de hábitos Hoje os milénios
falam muito da transformação da Posse
para o uso muitos deixaram de ter um
interesse e adquirir sua carta de
habilitação ou ter um carro financiado
de alguma forma
nós estamos sempre preocupados o que que
vai disputar o nosso indústria é mas com
calma e observando essas oportunidade
pensamos no carro por assinatura Ué o
carro por assinatura assim como um canal
de streaming que nem um canal de
streaming por quê Porque que não pode
ser um carro pelo uso para que as
pessoas possam tirar da frente a
manutenção pagamento de IPVA e pior
ainda aquele momento chato que é se
desfazer do carro
Nós criamos o carro fácil no intuito de
tirar o estresse da Posse e pensar
apenas no uso do veículo
e as oportunidades elas estão todas à
nossa frente o que nós precisamos é ter
um olhar atento e que ser criativos para
dar soluções que se integrem as
necessidades sociais
ambientais e que protejam o futuro do
nosso planeta
obrigado a
[Aplausos]
E aí